今日はよろしくお願いします
えーと あの座らないとできない
[笑い]えーと あの今日はテーリーガータ
テーリーガータですね
あのもう一つの経典で
すごい早く終わると思います今日は
ですからね そのあたりは残り時間で質問用意してください
[笑い]講演聞かないで質問ばっかり考えてるかと思いますが
どちらでもいいんだけど
えーとですね あの私ね
あのいろいろ日本語訳を送られたので
自分で分析して訳したり分析したりすることをしなかったんです
はい クンニカ長老の えーと
メルマルの対話 まああの
まあご存知でしょうね
お釈迦様の弟子たちの中で
このいくつかこの有名の方々はね
阿羅漢になってからあの語ったものをね
歌としてあの記録されているんですね
学者の方々は この歌だからね
これは一番古いんだと
散文は後で付けたものだという何の根拠もない話をしますが
あの仏教学者っていうのは
この一応西洋で決めた学術的な方法を取っているし
で しかし あのこちらでもね
かなり優れた学問もありましたけどね
西洋よりも古くてね で
ちょっと仏教学の場合
ちょっと問題がありまして
この最初はキリスト教の方々がね
この野蛮人の宗教って何なのかとね
真面目に調べたくて研究を始めたんですね
だからペイガニズムという野蛮人の宗教っていう先入観が消えてなかったんですね
まあ研究はそれなりに真面目ですけど
やっぱりあの先入観でいろんな分析のところでいろいろ問題が起きたりする
で 大事なポイントはきれいさっぱり捨てたりもする
基本になったのは聖書の研究のやり方なんですね
聖書を研究する場合は
聖書っていうのは神の言葉であって
間違うはずがないという先入観でやっているんですね
それでセムジ言語やらいろいろ古いあのいろんな言語を調べたりとかね
で それからそれもおかしいということで
また現代になってくると
さらにキリスト教の研究はね
変わってしまったんだけどね
最終的にはこれはもう神の言葉ではなくて
あちらこちらで人々が勝手に書いたものをね
より集めたものであると
原文なんかは見つかりっこはないんですね
で まあ旧約聖書はユダヤ人のものだからね
それはそれなりにしっかりしていますけど
問題は新約聖書で だからそちらではこの神がいて
神の子供がいて で こいつは子供か神かどちらかよくわかりませんだけどね
[笑い]まあいいキャラですけどね
それ以外に私物の信仰はペイガニズムというか
野蛮っていう感じで それで仏典でお釈迦様が超した能力でこういうことを言ったとか言ったら
これはありえませんかと
[笑い]内容はすごい大事な内容なんですけどね
何々神とこういう風な会話対話しましたといったら
これはアウト それはありえない
それはイエス様だけですね
奇跡あるのはというすごい先入観があって
そのまま 日本の研究の場合はそのままなんですね
それは良くないと 当然間違いやってこと
自分の国ではね 考えてはいたんだけどね
それで私は日本に来てね
この新しい仏教仏典をね
大乗仏典であろうか どんな仏典であろうが
研究する場合は 我々はそうじゃなくて
新しい学術的な方法を考えなくていけないんではないかと
言ったらお前の話聞くもんかってね
捨てられてしまったけど
それからちょっと半年間の研究にアメリカから若い人が出て
そんなにパーリ語 sanskrit語の詳しくないのでなくて
英訳で研究している人で
その人はこのアイデア出したんだったとか
私ってばこれからこういう風にいい加減にするよって言ったらね
一応私は一つやってみせたんだけどね
まあ私の研究は捨てられませんでしたけど
まああんまり若かな教授たちだけその方法に研究を書いたんですね
だから文献学は文献学でね
これなんでこんなくだらない話を言ってるのかっていうことは
このプンニカー長老っていうタイトルでしょ
これパーリ語でないんで
プンニカーって 原本ではパンナーなんですね
だから派手に中村先生は結構すべるところは結構ありましたけどね
中村先生は典型的なヨーロッパのあの
それこそ仏教に適していない学術のやり方で研究された方の最古の方なんですね
偉大なる方ですよ 中村先生はね
まあ中村元先生はね それは全然問題ないんだけどね
だからこの芸の中で この長老にをね
プンニカーと呼ばれる一箇所あるんですね
それだったらもう芸の中だから
タイトルははっきりプンナー長老とありまして
注釈書もプンナー長老で
プンニカーという名前はほとんどないんですよ
では なんで芸の中に入っているのかということで
これは相当の勘違いなんですね
あとで説明します じゃあ
で パーリ語ではプンナーテーリーガーターですね
プンナー長老の歌 名前はプンナー
プンナーっていうのはサンスクリットでプーナなんですけど
あの ごく一般的なインドの名前なんですね
それはいろいろ変えたりで
よく有名で このプールニマという
もしかすると女優さんもいるみたいですけど
よくわからない プールニマって
プールニマといえば満月という意味で
プンナーっていうのはパーフェクトという円っていう意味なんです
完成という意味の言葉で
プンナーだけ使わないで
それにいろいろ形容詞
接尾とかいろいろつけたりして
いろんな名前変えたりはする
この阿羅漢長老の名前はプンナーなんですね
プンニカーじゃないんです
ウダーハーリアハンシーテサダーウドカモータリンアイヤナンダンダバヤビータワーチャードーサバヤッティタ
で これから中村先生の訳はそのままパクって入れてあります
これパクリ簡単やというと
私にとっては簡単ではないんです
私与えられたテキストは PDF で
そこからは全然コピーペーストできないんだからね
もう全部一つ一つ読めない漢字まで打たなくちゃいけない羽目になっちゃったんです
結構苦労して 自分で訳せたら簡単なのね
怒りながら自分に対して
水込み女として私は寒い時にも常に水の中に入りました
これこの棒が私は気に入らないんですね
夫人たちから罰せ れるのを恐れおののいて
また言葉で怒りを発せられるのを恐れ悩まされてとかね
これ上にすればよかったのにね
だからもっとあの これはパーリ語の順番で中野先生訳しようと頑張ってるんですね
パーリ語の単語の順番で
だからこれは結構腕がないとね
結構技がないとできることじゃないんですね
だって日本語にしなくちゃあかんだからね
完璧な日本語にわかりやすくね
ですから そこでちょっとニュアンスがね
消えて しまいますね で
動詞の節が先に出すっていうことがよくありましてね
私は寒くても毎日水をくんだんです
毎日毎日水をくんだんです
なぜかというと この婦人たちにもう殴られたりするんだからね
すごく罵られて怒鳴られて
ちょっと間違ったらね
だから怯えて 怖くて 朝早く起きて
寒くて震えて 毎日水をくんでいるんだよと
で 何のことか皆さんわからないです
それは注釈書で もうストーリーを注釈書はあまり良くないんですね
持ってきたんだけどね
うーん で 過去ブッダの話から始まるんだからね
これ注釈書の伝統っていうのは
このごく一般の人々ね
これ召使いの女性なんですね
いわゆる知識人でも何でもないんです
おそらく文字も書けない
で 召使いっていうのはすごい格が低くて
死ぬまで仕事しなくちゃいけないんですね
インドのカースト制度ではね
自分のカーストを破って上に上ることはありえない
できない 不可能 財産は一部の人々だけ握ってるんですね
財産握っていたカーストはシャトリエといってね
王家ですね 王家というのはもうたくさんの人々を支配しているんですね
まあこんな法律も何でもあるわけじゃないんですね
やりたい放題で だからハチャメチャ金があるんだけど
仕事はしない ただもう自分の土地を誰かに奪われないように
まあ軍事 through で仕事はする
まあそれだけなんですね
で 商売やってるカーストは別でね
商売やってるカーストにはまあ金持ちになることはできましたけどね
まあそれでも土地がないんですね
土地が何とかして買わなくちゃいけないんですね
これ大変売ってくれないんですね
皆様 祇園精舎の物語知ってると思いますけど
あの祇園精舎っていうのは
あなたビンディカという人が寄付したものなんです
彼に土地がないんですね
ものすごい金があるんです
商人だから 銀行マンですね
ほとんど その人は ですから財産があるんです
だからジェダという王家の人に
あなたいっぱい土地を持ってるんだから
この土地この人使いませんよ
結局は ただまあ日本の山みたいな感じで
まあ国のものですけども
管理も何もなくてね 放っておいてだけなんで
だからまあ売ってくれと
売りません 売りません
俺はものすごくしつこく
売りません 金いくらでも出しますよと
そんな金の価値がないんです
いや 売りませんと言ったら
これは本当かどうか分かりませんだけどね
金貨で小判で振ってもね
あげませんよと言ったら
この人はあんた値段言いましたねとかね
これインドの覚えてください
インドの商売はそういう商売なんです
日本の文化習慣と違います
日本では物の値段があるでしょ
その値段で文句を言わないで買って帰る
高いなと思ったら買わなきゃいいんですね
もうちょっと安くしてくれませんかって日本では言いません
だいたい大会社作ってる品物以外は適当な値段つけてるんです
だから値段交渉する必要はないんです
大会社が作っているのは
もうこれはもう結構くだらないとんでもない値段なんですね
まあそれはそれで インドではもう値段言ったらもう買ったことになっちゃうんです
逃げられなくなっちゃうんです
時々あの もう我々巡礼に行く場合はね
すごいガラクタもうもう 10円も価値ないものは
10ドル10ドルと言ったりするんですね
いいえいいえですよと言ったっても
もう聞いてくれない  10ドル10ドルしかありですかとかね
それで あのね こんなガラクタはねと私は一回気が失敗したことありましたからね
これは 10ドルとか 1ドルの価値もないでしょうと
まだいらないんだと やられちゃって 1ドルで買うはめになっちゃったんです
最終的に  10ドルと言った品物がね
そういう世界だからね
だから昔からそういう文化なんですね
だからジェーダ王子が小判で拭いても敷いてもね
売るわけないんだと 売らないと言ったって値段言ったんですね
というこれは適切な値段ではなく
すごい天文学的な価値なんですね
価値言ったんだから あなた売ったんだからもうしょうがないですと
いや 売ってない 売ってないと
言って裁判かけるんですね
裁判官 裁判官がね 仕方ない
あなた値段つけちまったよと
あなた言った値段は 相手は相手の買う気をね
殺す目的で言った値段かもしれませんだけど
値段は値段ですね あの値段言ったのは
このアナンダビンダサさんが諦める
あの値段ではもう誰がどんなバカがいるんですか？商人だから
まず 大体利益を考えるんですね
だからその人の気持ちをきれいさっぱり消滅する目的で言った値段ですけど
でも値段言ったんだからね
あなたは値段を宣言しちまったよと
言って仕方がない あの値段で売るはめになったんです
ですから そのストーリーで読めるのは
この商人たちに金があっても土地がない
クシャトリヤ族の連中には土地があってバカなんですね
だいたいもう遊んでるばっかりで
だからいつでも政治家はバカなんですよ
もうだからそいつの人々
政治家って だから昔から今でも世界はろくなことないのはそういうわけなんです
だから哲学者はね 政治っていうのはこうであるべき
あであるべきと言うんだけど
政権は取れないんですね
ギリシャでもね いろいろ政治理論とかね
言葉はデモクラシーとか
それは全部ギリシャの言葉ですからね
で 出ていたんだけど なかなか
まあそんな話役に立ちませんね
だからこの社会システムの中で
もう自分が生まれた家で決まった仕事
で生活しなきゃ だからプンナさんがもうこういう大金持ちの家で召使いとして生まれて土地ないんだから
そこら辺でご主人の土地で住んでるんですね
うーん それで水をくんでいたんですね
だからこんな正確な人が大阿羅漢になって
ブッダに認められて 仏典にも言葉載るまでになってくると
なんか注釈書の文化になってくると
なんか変だなと思ったんでしょうかね
いつでもこの方々はすごい徳を積んで
過去何々ブッダの時代で
こういうこういうことをやって
ここで死んで ここで生まれて
ここでこうやって生まれて
これぐらい徳を積んで
最後にブッダの時代でこの家に生まれたっていう風になっちゃうんですね
私はそのストーリーこちらありますけどね
大変な素晴らしいか徳を積んで
そんなに徳を積んでるんだったら
なんで召使いに生まれたんですかね
だから我々現代人的な思考では分析しないんですね
私はそれほど徳があるんだったらね
なんで 召使いに生まれたんですかとかね
社会学的な目で見ると
そんなことじゃなくてね
普通見ると金持ちが頭悪くて
貧乏の人は頭すごく賢いっていうのは普通でしょ
だから私も全くもうノート買うお金もない時代では
若い頃はね 頭がものすごく鋭かったんです
ノート買うお金ないんだから本買えないでしょうに
だからちょっと ちょっと貸して貸してとかね
ちょっと貸してと 取ってみるんです
暗記しておくんですね
だからノート買うお金さえもない
本買っちゃったら一生だって読めるでしょ
だから自分の経験では
自分が本買えるようになってからはほとんど頭悪くて
誇らしげに買って置いておくんで読まない
昔はちょっと 30分ぐらい貸してとかね
借りてもらって サーっと読んで
はい どうぞと それでページまでもう頭にあるわ
何ページに何 こんなページにこれやったとかね
必死なんですよ 生き延びることは
だからそれって普通じゃないかなとね
今もこの現象は世の中にあるんですよ
だからこの今のインドにもあるんですよ
この全くのもうもう普通のこの労働クラスのね
人々とちょっと喋ってみると
もう腰が抜けちゃうんですね
あのすごい観察能力ともの知ってることに
それですごいインテリの人々と私
喋ったことあるんだけど
何度も一緒あって いつでもすぐ理論
私はピシピシと潰してみるんです
そこでボロ服を着て体洗ったことない
ものすごい乞食と喋っちゃうと困っちゃったなとかって感じになるんですよ
だから頭いいんです それに別に過去でこんなこんなこんな功徳を積んだとかってなくたって
まあいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
はい そこであのプンナさんが
これストーリーはっきり出てこない
もう私はどこかに思い出はあるんだけど
この召使いの時の会話だけやったところがあって
そこはちょっと見つからなかったんですね
いろいろ検索で調べたんだけど
ちょっと見つからなかったんですね
紙の本ないんだからね
紙の本だったらもう結構早く見つかるんだけどね
で  ここは阿羅漢になってからの対話ですけど
そこはまあ当然私は思うのは
このプンナ大阿羅漢が自分で作った歌ではないかもね
これはもう偉大なる方だから
その方にも一つワンセクションあげましょうということで
まあゴーストライターっていうんですかね
当時の で 彼女のエピソードを美しい歌にした可能性があります
それは学者はあまり気づかないところなんですね
なんで学者疑問にしないんだ？プンナっていうのはどう見たっても全くの教育一切ゼロなんですね
こんな難しい芸作る場合は相当大変なんです
ただ文法知っただけでできません
かなり大変なんです これは超エリートの学者にしかできないんです
詩を作ることは そこでお釈迦様みたいな
これはそのタイプになってくると
日常会話でも詩で会話する場合もあります
自分の国でもこの言語
音楽的にすごい超エリートになってくると
瞬時に歌作っちゃうんですよ
それはパーリの芸よりも難しい
シンハラ語の場合は音律だけじゃなくて
この文字までいろいろ合わせなくちゃいけないんですね
で 私も若い時はね なんか真似しようかなと思ったりしてね
いろいろやってみるんだけど
結構大変なんですね で
東国のサンスクリット語もそうでしょうし
インドの言語ではこのエリートの方々はね
インテリのインテリの方々はまあ普通会話に芸を入れるということはどういったことはないのです
あえて言いたいことは歌にして言う
すぐその場で作られる
教育何もゼロの方にとっては
普通のこのその方々は喋る言語もインテリの言語ではなくて
このスラング言語別にあるんですよ
だからどう考えてもこの前のね
長老の歌の場合でもね
うーん その方々に作れるのかっていうね
とにかくテーラワーダ
テーリー型っていうのは
三蔵経の中でもかなり古い層に入ってるんだから
こう偉大なる方々はね
そのエピソードを丁寧に記録したっていうことでしょうね
だから記録係がいて すごい真剣
真面目に記録するんですね
はい これでボンナさんがバロンに聞くんですね
カッサブラームナ トワン
ビート サガ ウダカ モータリ
ヴェーダ マーネーヒ ガッテーヒ
シータン ヴェーダヤ セー
ブサン こういうのは歌えるもんなんですね
カッサブラームナ トワン
ビート サガ ウダカ モータリ
ヴェーダ マーネーヒ ガッテーヒ
シータン ヴェーダヤ セー
ブサンという風な歌えるものなんですね
歌ですからね それで言葉すごく美しく
我々にとって皆様には関係ないんですけどね
私たちはすごく美しくインパクト強く感じる単語を選んで選んで言ってますね
このウェーダマーネーヒガッテーヒ
ウェーダマーナっていうのはぐるっと体震える
ガッタっていうのは体のこと
それからちょっと難しい動詞になってシータンウェーダイセイブサン
あのブサンっていうのは単語が超エリートでないと見つからないんです
なぜならば ブサンというのはたくさんということでね
で その場でその場で意味を変えるんですね
普通の単語はバフなんですね
さんすうで言ったらブというなるんですね
バフも使いますけどね
これブサンになってくるのは
これかなり能力がないとこの単語を選べないんです
シータンウェーダイセイブサンはあまりにも寒さをあなたは感じているんだよと
ちょっとあまりなんですね
ちょっと寒いなところじゃないんです
はい バラモンよ これナクムス訳
バラモンよ あなたは誰を恐れていつも水の中に入ったのです
入ったのですか？あなたが
あなたは手足がなんて言ったら
震えながら  震えながらひどい寒さを感じています
あのでもあのドラマチックじゃないんですね
訳は だから体全体的にぐるっと震えながら
並の寒さじゃないんですね
あまりのひどい寒さを感じて水に入っているんですと
水の中に潜っているんです
この女性が水を汲むだけ
これも嫌で嫌でやっているんです
でも自分が水を汲まなかったら殴られて
蹴られて 罰せられてひどい目にあるんですね
人間扱いされないんですね
メス牛 だから生き物としてやっぱり身を守りたいんです
だから私にとってはこれぐらい苦しみがあってやってます
あなたは誰のことを怯えているんですかねとかね
心配して聞くんですね
このゲの場合は私が今日見つからなかったんだけど
読んだところで彼女が朝早くまあ寒くて震えて水汲むために川に行ったんだけど
バラモン人が入ってるんですね
だからカーストの低い彼女にとっては川に入れないんですね
待たなくちゃいけないんですね
ひどい状態なんです こいつはどれぐらい川の中に入っているかわからないでしょうに
出ていくまで待たなくちゃいけない
遅くなっちゃうと 自分が殴られる
それで あの どちらでも出てこないんだけど
この日の出前に水に入るんですよ
あえてウェーダセーテン唱える
唱えて太陽が昇ると終わりなんです
そうすると この女の人にとっても遅いんですね
だから怒っていたでしょうね
当時では これはもう後で阿羅漢になってからこの記録しているところだから
そこは綺麗に亡くなっているんですね
俗世間的な感情ね だからこういう歌を作った方々はまあ確かに阿羅漢たちですよ
だからまあ美しく書くだけでね
こういう怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ
区別 差別の感情は全部もう入ってないんですね
でもこれユーモアでしょうね
結局はバラモンバカにして
私ならこんなもんでやられちゃいます
殴られます あなたバラモンでしょうに
バラモンっていうのは一番上のカーストで金持ちではないんだけど
生殖者なんですね あなたなんで？という
はい バラモンの答え 知ってるでしょって
じゃあなー
きわたまんぼうてぃぷんにけえぱりくっちゃっしーかるんたんくさらんかんまんるんらんたんかたぱーぱかんじゃあなんじゃなんてわたまんぼうてぃぷんにけえぱりくっちゃっし
ーかるんたんくさらんかんまんるんらんたんかたぱーぱかん
[笑い]意味を出してから説明します
これ水浴と言うんですか？ 水浴です
水浴をなすバラモン曰く
これも私はあまり好まない文章の書き方ですけど
プンニカーサンヨー しかし
そなたは私が良い行いをなし
悪い行いを止めていることを知りながら
しかもそのようなことを質問している
だからそれほど長くないんです
パーリ ジャーナンディ ワタマン ボーティ
そこであのポイントがあるんで
これはボーティっていうのはもう人を呼ぶ時の使う単語なんですね
あまり言葉の意味はそれほど悪くないんですね
これは英訳に翻訳できないんですね
昔知らない人 江戸時代ではあのね
旦那さんって言うでしょ
商人たちとかね 私の言われてもあのね
旦那とか旦那って何ですかとか
でも旦那という単語には別に日本語では別の意味があるんですよ
あるんですけど 別の使い方あって
今は最近使わないんだけど
前は使っていたんです
あのね 旦那さん だから人の人を呼ぶ時の単語なんです
あれはかなりいい意味がある
旦那さんっていうのはパーリ語
仏教用語で人にものをあげる
あげた人々の面倒を見る人なんですね
だからかなり敬語なんです
ボーティっていうのはたくさんある人は豊かな人っていう意味なんですね
幸福な方よ でもその意味は入ってない
旦那さんって言ったってもね
何かくれる人です 全くないでしょうに
それは日本語になっちゃってて
夫にも旦那と言うでしょうね
夫は旦那じゃないんですけどね
何もやってくれないんです
でも仕事をして収入を持ってくるんだから
その意味に無理やりに旦那という言葉を入れてるんですね
本当は旦那っていうのはそうじゃなくて
もう結構人々のために頑張っている立派な性格の人のことなんですね
そこでボーという言葉は人を呼ぶためにある本当は意味のある敬語なんですけど
これは逆に使っているんです
お釈迦様にもボーと呼ぶんですね
時々 それは決まってこの他宗教の人々
お釈迦様を馬鹿にしたいんですね
見下したいんですね 見下したい時はボー
ボーゴート もうちょっとレベル高く
お釈迦様 ミスターみたいな感じで呼ぶ場合はバガンゴートマ
坊はババになる この単語には格変化はしません
バワンゴートも もっと仏弟子たちと仏教の人々がお釈迦様を言う場合はバンテーなんです
これはもう一番トップの単語なんです
今インド人はお釈迦様の場合はもう昔の方だからバガワンという言葉を使っているんですね
バガワンブッダ バガワンといえばすごい丁寧な敬語
これ上の敬語はないんですね
だからインド人が聖者とかね
サイババさんにもね バガワンサッチャスリサイババなんですね
昨日ネットで彼のちょこちょこっと見て楽しかったんだけどね
インチキやってるなと思って
バガワンというね バガワンっていう言葉
ボーディっていうのはもう
何て言いますか 目上の反対
目下の そういう人々を呼ぶ時
名前も知らないしね ですからボーディ
日本語ないんですね ね
お前っていう感じなんですね
君とか言ったらちょっと愛情があるんですよ
だから いい単語ありますよ
前にいる方という意味で
手前っていう言葉あるでしょ
あれどうやってするか
てめえになってますね
あれって敬語なんですけど
今どうなってるんですかね
自分の前にいらっしゃる方
手前 だからお泊まりさんにとってはと言ったら
何も感じてねえわと言ったらね
すごい だからこれはてめえって意味なんです
はっきり言えばボーディ
だから怒ってるって 目知ってるのに
そこでポンニカという単語が出てくるんです
名前知ってるんですね
彼女はポンナーっていうことは
ポンナーにも同じく敬語の反対
何でしたっけね 軽蔑語ですかね
よくわからない 軽蔑語を入れてるんです
言語学者 そこをわかってないんですね
そこで滑っちゃったんです
名前はポンナーに決まっている
ポンナーを軽蔑して呼ぶ場合はポンニケーなんです
これでポンニカと この芸だけ日本訳する場合はポンニカと言った方がいい
本当はさんはいらないんだ
その場合は 正しく訳するならば気にしなくてはいけないんです
だからポンニカ用なんです
さんの意味は入ってないんです
そこでカという接尾語
どんなものにも入れられます
名詞なら そうするともう大したことない
なんだこれって意味になっちゃうんです
だからカーストのトップのバラモンがカーストの一番低いのはポンナーさんにポンニケって呼ぶのは普通ポンニケって呼ぶでしょうと
だからこのインドのこの修行方法っていうのは
これ誰にだって知ってることなんです
これで腹が立ちますよ
バラモンについては いくらなんでも
どんなカーストの人でもね
バラモンたちの修行を知ってるでしょうと
知ってるくせに聞くんだと
だから説明するんです
それでも どういうことかというと
私がカロンタンクサラカン
私は善行をやってますよと
それからルンダンタンカテパーパカン
私がやった罪を今壊しているんだと
ルンダティっていうのはこのもう壊す
いじめる コアっていう意味なんですね
だから悪をいじめてもう食わしながら善行為をしているんだよと
はい 知ってるでしょうという私の中間に待って
で 水浴はインドの大衆が行っていたんですね
インドのもう まあインド教は一番多いバラモン教は一般人のね
まあインドの宗教だからね
で 水浴っていうのは あの
まあ普通の習慣なんですね
ガンガー川 それを母川なんですね
世界の川の母はガンガー川だそうです
だからどれほどインド人が厳しいかと
ガンガーっていうのは変わった意味なんです
だからガンジス 今ガンジスと言うでしょ
私たちは だから川と言わなくちゃいかんですね
あの日本語のこの何とかこれも川
川でしょう 読み方わかりますね
河川 河川で川 川なんですよね
で ガンガーで言えば川なんですね
これだから母川なんですね
他全部まあ 他の川には別な名前をつけなくちゃいけないんですね
例えばアチラワティという川
アチラワティ ガンガーなんです
ガンガーはガンガー ガンガーでアチラワティはアチラワティ・ガンガー
だからレベルが低いんですね
ガンジス川に流れる他の川も
あの沐浴できるんですね
ガンジス川につなげ つなげているんだからね
それ全て聖地 ガーと言うんですね
インド語で ガーというところ決まってあるんですね
で 現在もヒンドゥー教徒たちは実行しているんです
だから沐浴っていうのは今ももうひどいもんですよ
もう よくやっています
これで罪が綺麗になると
このガーの中で一番 あのトップのガーとは
このお釈迦様が初転法輪を取って
初転のところにあるバラナシなんですね
バラナシはあの ヒンドゥー陣営の心臓部で
仏教の心臓部になっているんですね
そこにはガーがあるんですね
ガンジーが一番汚いところやと思いますね
世界で一番汚い ひどく汚れている川なんですよ
だからもう工場からそのまま流しちゃう
もう下水そのまま流しちゃう
そこで人を燃やしてね
火葬して 半分ぐらい火葬して
お金ある人は全部 燃やしちゃいますけど
お金ない人はほんのちょっと紛いで体を燃やして
そのまま捨てる川に そこでまた沐浴して
罪を流すという習慣なんですね
仏教とジャイナ教は認めない修行法です
だからその二つの宗教以外はもうみんなやってるんです
そこではだいたい世の中で浄めの品物として水を使っているわけですね
だからインド文化になってくると
ヒンドゥ教ではなくてね
だから仏教は仏教で ヒンドゥ教はヒンドゥ教で
インド文化でいえば仏教もインド文化なんですね
インド文化になってくると
水が浄めグッズの一つなんですね
日本はそんな見たことはあまりないんです
禊っていう習慣がありますよね
神道で 水に浸かって身を清めるというのを修行としてやっている宗派もありますけど
やっぱりやるみたいですね
で キリスト教の洗礼も水にね
漬けちゃうんですね 人を
再び生まれてもらうために
だったら私に頼んでくれ
私は再び生まれる 死ななくちゃあかんだからね
分ぐらい浸けとくんだけどね
生まれ変われなかったら私のせいじゃないから
神がもう無視したっていうことになりますからね
そこは今省略してちょっと水をかけるだけでね
大体洗礼は赤ちゃんにやっちゃいますからね
赤ちゃん水の中に入れちゃうとね
お母さんにやらせてくれませんからね
まあちょっとなんとかっていうね
まあそういう習慣ありますから
このこれは文化的なもので
まあ宗教と当然関係ありますけどね
その場合はあまり宗教的な問題なく
どんな宗教でも水は清めグッズの一つというのって持っています
お釈迦様はそう思ってなかったんです
お釈迦様は水っていうのは飲むものと体洗うものだと
ちゃんと沐浴しなさいと戒律で決めてるんです
最低月回 だからインドで泥だらけで裸でもう汚い修行者がいるところで
仏教の弟子たちはもう
まあ最低週回はね 体洗いなさい
お釈迦様はしょっちゅう体洗って綺麗に
それは普通常識的な意味で
衣払って もう月一回でも髪の毛と髭を剃ってとかね
そういう風に清潔にいなさいと
でも仏教文化になってくると
水は浄めグッズになっちゃうんですね
我々もね テーラワーダ仏教会でもお経あげたりして水を配ったりしますね
それは文化的な習慣になっているんですね
はい 偈があります 水浴の偈 Yo
ce buddo daharo vā pāpakaṃmaṃ pakuñjati. Dhākābiṣec
enā so pi pāpakammā pamuccati.
ああ これ読んです 間違ったね
私がね Yo ce buddo daharo vā pāpakaṃmaṃ pakuñjati. Dhākābiṣe
cenā so pi pāpakammā
pamuccati.老いた人でも若い人でも
およそ悪い行いをなすならば
彼は水浴によって悪行から
多分逃れるだと思います
逃れることができる 私は逃れると思ったんだけど
出てこなかった この感じは
えーと まあこれバラモンさんがね
説明するんです すごい哲学ですね
年寄りであろうが若者であろうが悪行為したならば
ダカービセイチェナアビセーチェナっていうのはこの洗礼と同じ意味なんですね
キリスト教のアビセーチェという洗礼ですよ
[笑い]で あの王が死んじゃって
次の人が王にあのする場合は
この王っていうのは何か
何か聖なる仕事みたいね
昔の人間にはね 王王様は一般人じゃないんだと神だと思っていたんだからね
だから一般くだらない人間がもう王が死んじゃったら次の人をね
しなくちゃあかんでしょうに
ある儀式が行うんですね
それはもうどんな国でもやっちゃいます
それで俺が偉くなっちゃったっていう
もうくだらんことやっちゃってね
で コーロネーションって英語で言いますけど
日本語で何と言いますかね
えっと 冠譲って言います
うん なんとか その時はこのバラモン人がこの王になる人の頭にこのちょこっと水をかけるんですね
これはもう結構声を上げて呪文唱えて
もうかなりの厳しいしきたりで
その時使うのはほら貝なんですね
ほら貝は左巻きのほら貝を使うんです
だから左巻きがものすごい珍しいんですね
あれは遺伝子変化かどうかはわかりませんだけど
もうなかなか見つからないんで
左巻きのほら貝 それはインド文化では右巻きと言うんだけど
実際左巻きなんですけど
で ほら貝を右で取くんですね
あれが左手で取らなくちゃいけないんですね
だから かなり珍しい品物だったら
すごい得が高いものになっちゃうんですね
それで そのほら貝で水をちょぴっと頭にかぶってやって
そのほら貝は聖なるものとしてまた大事に置いておく
また二度と使わない 次の人が王になるまで
で それ終わってから冠をつけてあげるんですね
イギリスのコーロネーションというのは
もしかするとネットでいじったら見つかると思いますけど
同じことをやってますよ
だから浴びせちゃってる
そういうことなんですね
だから正しい訳するならば
水浴によってではないんですよ
別な単語をちょっと入れないとね
水浴という  冠譲  冠譲による水浴冠譲によって
水浴冠譲によって悪行から抜かれることができる
はい こんな長老がもう次に答える
コヌテ イデ マッカシ アジャナンタッサ アジャナトコ ダカビ セチェナ ナマ パタ カンマ パムッチャティ
また日本にか苦い湧くと
だからバラモン人の言葉が本物の言葉にしているんですね
いい加減勘違い見かけ知りふりしたんですけど
[笑い]そもそも誰が無知でありながら無知なる者に
何でしたっけ？推測することによって悪行から逃れることができるという
このことを問いたのですか
これ私の訳だったら アホのアホ
誰ですかと アジャーナンタッサ
アジャーナク もうアホだけじゃなくて
このアジャーナンタッサもアホのアホ
いわゆる無知の無知 あの無知の無知
あのアホのアホは誰ですかと
こんなこと言ったのはと
という意味なんです 本当のところは
しかし これ阿羅漢たちが作った偈だから
すごい敬語をアジャーナンタッサ
アジャーナとすごいなんか丁寧に喋ってますけど
意味はアジャーナンタッサが全く無知な人
無知な人の無知 だからプンナ長老にから見れば
これアホみところやとかね
このアホが誰ですかと
黙々とにではなくて 推測によって悪行がから抜かれると言ったバカが誰ですかねという質問ですね
それからもうプンナ長老がもうずっと喋っていくんですね
サッガンノーナガミサンティサッベマンduカカッチャパーナーガーチャススマラーチャイエチャンイェウデカーチャラー
まあここは問題ないんです
さて もしもそうであるならば
カエルも龍 亀も龍っていうのは蛇なんですね
蛇もワニも その他の水中に潜るものどもも
すべて天界に赴くことになりましょう
で 私の訳では確かに天国に行く
ノーナ もうそれはもう疑いなく
なんですね もう水ヘビは死後も天国も決まっている
もう確保し 確定している
だって生まれつき水の中にいるんだから
罪ってひとかけらもないでしょう
カエルさんとかね これは中村先生はね
天に生まれることになりましょうという風に
なんとかそういう風な感じに入れ替えてはいるんですね
これはデフィニティブという風な英語でやってないと思いますね
だから 日本の人はもう英訳見ながら日本語の作んなきゃいけない
そこで厳しいことを次に言うんですね
だからそんなね 甘い話じゃないんです
この偈は オーラッビカースーカリカーマッチカーニガバンドカー
チョーラーチャワッジャガター
イエーチャンイエーパパカンミノーダカービセーチェーナテーピーパパカンマカモチェレー
私は歌ってはいけないっていうことにも動画を up しました
また もしもそうであるならば
これから私は読めません
屠用者ですかね  屠用者
まあ必死にね 殺す人々
ととんしゃ？ ととんしゃ
売婦 えーと  有力者  とにかくまあ一応あの漢字見たら意味がわかるので
まあこういう訳にしていると思いますけどね
オーラッビカーっていうのは山羊殺して肉にする人々ですね
インドでは肉食べていたんだけど
この肉業者をすっごくもう悪人っていう
社会からもう社会に入れてくれないんですね
だからまあ離れたところで生活して
ヤギを殺ったり牛豚を殺ったりして
肉にして売って生活する
魚の場合も同じ魚取って売る
だから買って食べるんだけど
この業をやってる人々のことはもうすごい差別的で
もうあの追い出すんですね
もうものすごい罪人だと
それから土足 土足でしたっけ
盗賊  盗賊 それから死刑囚
他の悪行為をする人々
誰でもね 水に入ったら全て罪がもう流されちゃって OK ですね
これ厳しい批判でしょう
水に入ったら罪が消えていくならば
あなたよりエビの方が先に天国に行くんだよと
ヘビに魚に勝てっこないんだから
カエルさんにも それだけじゃなくて
世の中でも極悪人たちがまあ言っちゃうと水に入れば大丈夫ですもん
そこで私の注なんですけど
道徳を気付かず否定する
だからここでの仏教的なポイントは
このバラモンたちが表面的にはいいことをやっているように見えるんですね
皆様方はできればネットで調べてください
あのいくらでもデータありますから
この沐浴の習慣やり方
決まっている日に占いで星占いで一年何回何回も出てくるメールが来るんですけど
まあそういうすごい吉日が出てくるんですね
その日にその決まった時間になってくると
ドカーンと水に入っちゃうんです
ガンジス川に それ前に色々準備修行があるんですよ
この準備修行して で  1週間ぐらいかけて
もう大体な祭りなんですね
大体軽々と 200人ぐらい迷子になったりするとか
子供たちとかね 大変なんです
で ちょっとちょっと捕まっちゃうと不vareで死ぬこともあります
だから年に一回 二回しか来ない吉日だからね
この日でもう水に入ったら
もう全部罪が流されちゃって幸福になりますよという考えもありますし
修行者は毎日やる場合もあるしね
[笑い]そこで彼らがわかってない
要するに罪を犯してもその決まった日で
罪悔すれば罪が滅びるんだよと
だから罪を犯したことに悩む必要もないし
懺悔する必要もないし
だから何だと あんたは私の家に強盗に入って
全部先生全て財産持っていったのはどうだろう
別に私は君の店に入ってきたんだからね
今も修行中だからね 黙っていなさいと
言えるんですよ 向こうはそんなことめても
あんた神を馬鹿にするつもりですかね
神を冒涜して あんたそれ幸せになりたいと思ってるの？逆に言うこともできる
とにかくこれはもう道徳を否定する教えなんですね
人は教理学的に道徳を否定する道を実行しているんですよ
唯一の神を信仰している方々も
知らず知らず道徳的な生き方と
人が自らの行為の結果を受けるのだという教えに逆らっているんです
これは仏教の批判なんですけど
この唯一の神を信仰すると
その人も道徳を否定しているんです
だから いい加減に唯一の神を信仰すれば大丈夫です
中途半端で 中途半端ではなく
原理的に神を信仰すると全く非道徳になるんです
なぜならば 神は全知全能
過去 現在 未来 全て知っている
それで神は全てのものを創造する
神が作った人間が100人殺したとする
それは神知ってるんです
神がどんな方法で どんな年齢で
自分が作った この人が8人殺すのか知っているんです
だから神のプログラムが動くのであって
人間が考えたプログラムでは世の中は動くわけじゃないんですね
イスラム原理主義者はそういう考えで
キリスト教原理主義者もこういう考えなんですね
中途半端に神を信じる人々は
神に祈りをするのはいいんだけど
私たちも頑張りましょうよと
一応念のためにと 教会に行って懺悔するのはいいんだけど
一応気をつけて悪いことしないようにしましょうよと
いくらなんでもこれはまずいと
だから神を無視する分が道徳的になるんですね
祈るんじゃなくて頑張れという場合は神を置いておけるんですね
キリスト教の原理主義者っての一部がね
神は完全な存在だから
欠陥のものを作るはずがない
だから人は病気になったら薬あげるなよと
それは神を冒涜することになるんだ
その通りですけど だから神様を信じるアッラー神様でよ神様を信じてる人々はね
バファリン一流も飲まないでいてほしいんですね
ガンにかかったら祈ればいいんです
で その方が世の中迷惑は早く終わりますけどね
冗談で言いますけどね
まあだからこの そういうことで
この新興宗教組織ですよ
あまり形式的なキリスト教はそんなくだらんことやりません
まあ形式的な普通のキリスト教組織はね
新興宗教組織っていうのはもうかなり厳しいことをやって
人に迷惑をかけたりする
だから新興宗教といえば
もうキリスト教系だけじゃなくてね
アジアだと全部仏教系になるんだからね
だからまあみんなダメなんですね
いくら文句言いたいものあったっても
この伝統的な既成宗教っていうのはね
まあ生き残ってるんだからね
だからそれほど社会に迷惑かけてないんです
そういうことで あのブッダの批判っていうのはね
すべて神に創造論を持ってきたら
神という単語を使わない
創造論 すべて創造論という哲学を持ってきたら
あんたは道徳を否定しているんだと
要するに人間何やってもいいんです
自分の生き方管理する必要はないんです
感情で 本能で好きなことをやっていければいいということになるんですね
次 サチエ・イマ・ナディ・オテ・パパン・ブッベ・カタン・ワホン・プンニャン・ピマ・ワヒヨン・テケナ・トン・パリ・バーヒロ
そこはすごい矛盾を見せてあげるんですね
この長老には もしもこれらの川の流れが
そなたが以前になした悪行を運び去ってしまうのであるならば
これらの流れは善行も功徳も運び去ってしまうでしょう
それによってそなたは善悪両者の外にあるものとなってしまうでしょう
大変です だから バラモン系の人々はそれに気づいてないんですね
だから善後っていうのは善行為
悪行為でしょ 人々やった行為でしょ
行為の結果 流されるならば
悪行為だけ流されて善行為残るということはないんですね
あの私たちは あの 例えばこの服なんかにいろいろ何て言いますか
この一点という出ますけど
なんか汚れがあって  シミですか？ シミがあって
これ出ていかない場合は
あの漂白剤入れちゃうでしょ？入れたらきれいに真っ白くなるでしょ
ちょっと色付いたものを入れてください
色を残して墨だけお願いします
できる？できませんね
私はいろいろ台所でね
色付いているタオルをね
色分けでこれで手を拭いて
これで皿を拭ける 決めているんだけど
まあちょっとなんか水で止まって水のあれ残っちゃうと石鹸ではいけないんですね
それであの漂白剤にそれ入れるんです
入れたら全部真っ白 もう色分けできなくなる
もう仕方ないんだから場所で
こっちにあるものはこのために
このタオルはこのためにと場所で区別するんです
初めは色分けでやっていたんだけどね
だから水に悪を流すことできるならば
一緒に全部流しちゃいますよ
そうするとあなた何者になるんですかね
もう人間扱いできない
もうただのもう機械というか荷物ということになるんだよと
だからそこを矛盾を教えてるんですね
これ矛盾という単語を使ってないんですね
そう そこはとても美しく議論しているんじゃなくて
対話なんですね この対話の中で
すごいすごいすごいすごい哲学的な論理方法が流れているんです
そこで仏教はいつでも客観的に議論する
科学的なんですね 水に悪を流す力があるならば
全部流すんですよ 例えば
お化粧していた女性が何かあちらこちらちょっと汚れちゃったんですね
体が そうすると川に入っちゃう
入っちゃうと お化粧だけ残って汚れだけ逃げてるんじゃないでしょう
全部流されますよ この人々は水に何か聖なる力があると思ってるんですね
これってすごい原始思考で
水が汚れをなくすってことが見えてくるんですね
水はいつでも浄化しますよ
汚れの水でも流しておけば綺麗に綺麗な水になっているんです
だからそれは物質的な働きでしょうしね
そこで我々は水によって物事は綺麗になるっていうことは勘違いで
人間のね 野菜とかね 例えばもう芋とかね
ジャガイモとか取ったら
まあいっぱい泥が生えて
これが水で洗うよりも流れる水に入れちゃうと
もっと綺麗に丁寧に洗えるんですね
ああ 綺麗になりました
清らかさは残っているではないでしょう
元に戻っただけですよ
あれは だからそこをちょっと勘違いして
宗教的な神秘的な意味をつけてるんですね
だからこの悪だけじゃない
全部流せますよというふうに言われるんですね
そこで導く ヤッサブラームナトワンビートサダーウダカモータリー
タメバブラクメマーカーシーマテーシータンチャビンハネ
そう言うんです バラモンよ
そなたがいつも恐れて水の中に入って
これイッタと言うんだそうですね
イッタ ところのそのことをなさるな
わからないな こんな翻訳
[笑い]バラモンよ 寒気がそなたの皮膚を束の間にないようになさい
まあ普通ではね ブラマンよね
あんたはね 何かに怯えて
何かを心配して水に入っているでしょう
これやらないでくださいと
これ良くないんだ あんたこんな苦労しないでください
このあなたの体がね こんな寒い水に入って
夏だったらいいんだけどね
これはそうじゃないんですよ
この日にちが インドは日本の冬ほど寒くないんだけど
逆にこの温める文化でもないんですね
暖房ないんですね 湯たんぽとかないんです
ネパールとかそこら辺に行ったってもね
だから寒さはなんとか
だから日本の寒さよりは厳しいんですね
だからこの温度計で見たら
まあそう大したことはないんだけどね
でも向こうはもう何もないんだから
だからそれで 水に入っちゃうと大変ですね
これやらないと この寒さであなたの皮膚をね
壊さないでください そこで注解いたすつもりですが
あとで注が出てきたら言います
はい バラモンが納得する
クン マッガ パティパンナ マム アリヤ マッガム サマナイ ダカ ビセッチナ ブーティ イマン サータン ダダ サータン ダダ ミティ
バラモン曰く 邪な道を踏み
踏みゆく  踏みゆく私を
あなたは正しい尊い道に連れて行ってくださいました
姉様よ 私はこのえーと水浴心もね
あなたに差し上げますと
すごい象徴的なんですね
あのー 沐浴するときはそれに決まってる服を
あのサータンっていうのは
これあの服じゃないんですね
布ですよ で まあそれ布で体を巻くとドーティって現代にインディゴでドーティって言いますけど
長い布で何かズボンのように巻くんです
ね 色々調べてみて あれ巻いたら
あのガンジーさんとかね
あのドーティなんですね
ちょっといた布で なんかなんかズボンのようなものを着ているような見えますけど
やっぱり足一本分外に出ますね
それでも インド人は別にズボンを別に作って
西洋的じゃなくてね インド
インド的なズボンもありますけどね
で この場合はこの上半身が裸で
腰に長い布をね ズボンのように巻くんですね
巻いて それで飯に入るんですね
だからどうせ当時では服っていうのはすごい高価なものになるんですね
だからみんな服の場合もすごいギリギリ節約するんですね
まあシャトゥリ族はそうじゃないんだけど
いくらでも取っちゃえばいいんだからね
作ってる人々から で 金を払う必要ないしね
自分の土地に住んで生活してるんだからね
まあそこ払いなさいと言えばね
で だからその他の人々は
バラモンの人々でも他の一般人も服をすごい大事にするんですね
そこでこの これはあなたにあげますと
このサータって長い布をね
だから長い布だから 出家のお坊さんたちにとってはすごく便利
これは切って縫い合わせて
まあ衣を作れるんですね
だから水浴衣ですね あなたに差し上げます
象徴的っていうのは 本人が綺麗さっぱりアホなことをやめたっていうことですね
この約束として はい あげます
さようならと この間違った生き方
これっきりしませんよと
はい 次に中が出てくるのです
中が来る前に皆様に質問します
これぐらいの対話で人の生き方は変わっちゃうんですかね
ちょっと馬鹿にされただけで
変わると思います  こんないと言葉に
きっとこのバラモンにとっては
善も悪も流れるんですかと
流しちゃうんですか？そしたらあなたは何者になるんですか？っていうところでグサッときたんだろうな
そんなそうなんですけど
私は言いたいポイントは結構議論したでしょう
人々の心っていうのは
そう簡単に自分の考え変えませんね
でも経典はお釈迦様の一言でもってガラッと心が変わるお話ばっかりじゃないですか
でも長く話せるんですよ
お釈迦様の場合はちゃんと順番で相手の思考
今何考えているのか そこからステップバイステップバイで持っていって持っていって
対話で持っていくんですね
こちらも対話形式で だからバラモンさんに考える暇が必要なんですね
だからなんで水でケラケラ鳴ると言ったんでしょうかと
誰が言ったんでしょうかとかね
だからこの人はすごいエリート学者でしょ
バラモン人だからね だから考えてみたら
歴史辿ってみたら そんな根拠もないしね
だから とにかくここはメインポイントだけ
経典でもこういうところでも
これは記録ですからね
起きた出来事をそのままビデオクリップ出してるわけじゃないんです
だからこれも恐らくこんな尼さんが作った経でもない可能性はいくらでもあります
だからこういう出来事が起きましたよと
だからそれは私たち説法するときはできるだけそこに詳しく言わなくちゃいけない
今までやっているのは
今日はそんなやる気がないんだからね
ちびちびしかやってないんだけどもね
はい 次に行きます 次って私の中なんですね
素直で真面目な性格 これは武道に対してすごく大事なことなんです
素直で真面目だったら誰だって悟れます
それは初期仏教のスタンスなんです
過去ヴィパッサナーブッダの時から苦毒すんですんで
もう苦毒有り余っていると悟るっていう話はないんです
過去ヴィパッサナーブッダの時からやってきたとかね
そういう話を持ってくると
なんか私は不公平感じるんですね
だから誰だって人間ならね
悟る可能性はあるんですけど
人間ですけど みんなへそ曲がりで素直じゃないんですね
それから真剣 真面目っていうところもないんですね
自分にとってやりやすいんだったらやるんだけど
これ人格変えることだから
かなり嫌でもやらなくちゃいけないところも出てくるんですね
自分の本能がやめろやめろと言っているのに
真面目に言ったことをやる
そこが必要なんですね
それから素直で自分の心を見る能力が必要なんです
その条件さえ揃っていれば
誰だって悟れます モナカの人
このバラモンにこれがあったんです
すごい素直でしょう お前
メスかい何様やということはなかったんです
え？ということで考えたんです
そこでこのバラモン性格
ものすごい罪は犯したくはないんですね
四五梵天に生まれ変わりたいんです
で 罪を犯したくはないんだけど
結構やっているんです
スイスイやっちゃう あるいは条件によってやらせていられない環境であったかもしれません
そうですね 例えば仏教のね
私たちの仲間の方々もちょっと話聞くんだけどね
あの飲み屋さんやったり
いろいろ何商売というんですか
そういう人に酒を勧めたりとかね
そうするとどうしようかと
そこはちょっと引っかかっちゃうんですね
仏教は酒飲んではいけないと言ってるし
私は飲まないし そういう私が人に酒を売って金を買って生活している
生計を立てている これで辞めちゃうと私も食べるものがなくなっちゃう
収入がパアになっちゃう
生きていなくちゃいけないし
という困っちゃうんです
その場合は だからそういう風に条件がね
いくら素直で正直でいたっても
そういうそうはうまく行かない条件もありますね
そうすると悪人があの
何といいますか 開き直る
しょうがないでしょう
私は漁師だから魚を捕らなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そんなことに罪ありゃあぐらいでいたって困りますよ
言っちゃうともうアウト
だから正当化する人が自分の行いをね
悪人ですね やってることは大したことではないかも
しかし 小さな罪でもやってしまったら正当化しないで素直に認める
この素直というのはそういうことなんです
決して正当化しない このプライドが割り込んできて素直でなくなっちゃうんです
隠しちゃうんですね 隠せなくなっちゃうと正当化する
弁解する だからそういう人格者というのはやっぱり少ないんですね
このバラモンはすごい信者で
悪は犯す 悪は起こしたくないということで怯えていたんですね
それすごい素直です それで誰かさんが誰かさんが言ったことに乗っちゃって
あまりにも悪を恐れていたんだから
言うことを何でもやる
なんか子供がひどい病気になっても治らない状態になった時の母親みたいな感じなんです
お医者さんがこれ治療はないんだからね
諦めなさいと 母親の子供を諦めなさいと言ったって意味がある？覚悟しなさいと
意味がないのでできないんです
そうすると何でもやる
その人の弱みはインチキ宗教世界の一番いいマーケットなんですね
これこれやったら病気が治ります
これこれやったら商売上手できますとか
なんとか そこで宗教がそこで商売して繁盛するんですね
だからこのバラモンのケースも同じく
あの自分自身では悪を犯したくない
もうなんかすごい悪に対して恐怖感を感じているんですね
でも毎日いろいろやってるでしょう
どうすればいいかと悩んで悩んでたところで
もう誰かにもう教えなさいと言われちゃったんです
だからこんな大長老 長老にも誰がその阿呆が
阿呆のアホや あなたにこんなこと言ったのは
やめなさい 論理的に語って見せる
この考え方にある矛盾を見せてあげる
それでバラモン人にとっては
あ この道があってない
すぐ納得することができたんですね
人は道徳を真剣に重んじるならば
やがて正しい道が現れるんです
だからこのバラモンが道徳を守りたいんですよ
真面目に道徳 真面目に守りたいんだけど
自分やっていることは非道徳的なんですね
だったらいたって簡単にやめてもらう
だからちょっとしたアドバイスでうまくいったのはそういうわけなんです
だからこのボンナー長老アマダンのすごいパワーというよりは
バラモン人の性格なんです
こんな長老にも結構口がうるさかったんだけど
もう厳しくビシビシと言っちゃうんだからね
すごいひどく言うんだから
それはいいんだけど それにプラスアルファでこの聞く側の性格もうまくはめたんですね
だから罪は犯したくない
道徳を大事に守りたい
それなら何でもやるっていう立場にいたんだから
あんたやってることは矛盾
そんなものやめてよ こんなことをしないでくださいと言うと
ちゃんとわかりました
この性格の強さを見せるのは
あのこの布あげますというところなの
もう決めたら決めたで中途半端じゃないんです
はい わかりました 今日から頑張りますと
今日から気をつけたんじゃないんです
はい あげます あげたら家にもう 1枚 3
枚ぐらい余分にあるわけないでしょ
当時ではね この人シャトリア族じゃないんだから
バラモン人はすごいインテリですけど
財産あったのは一部だけなんです
大体貧乏なんです そういうわけで皆様に言いたいのは
皆様そのままで真理を知りたい
道徳を守れと思っちゃうと
ちゃんと道が現れてきます
日常世界の中で もう気づいてひらめいてしまったってことは普通にあり得ることです
道徳を重んじていたが
哲学思考 見解などにはしがみ過ぎていなかった
もう一つ この人の場合は
私は長い間やってきたものだから
私の師匠が言ってくったものだから
あれは慣習なの 無知なの
そういう価値観に入れない
素直に言ったことをやる
やるんだけど この見解にしがみつくことはない
俺もこのバラモン人の性格に素晴らしいところなんです
そういうことで皆様に読み取れるんですかね
なんか私の解説から見ると
ボンナー長老によりも何か私はバラモン人を褒めてるんですね
なんか勘違いしてるんじゃないんでしょ
私はこれはボンナー長老が悟ったっていうことがすごいことやと報告する文章
歌ですけど よくよく見るとなんか
立派な人格者にボンナー長老にあったんです
会った時はとんでもない人でしたけど
瞬時に変わったんですね
それからこの見解にしがみついてないってことも
ものすごい人間に対する大事なことで
見解持っちゃうと 主義持っちゃうと
それが信奉のハンディなんです
ものすごい 時々よく昔やったことで
このカトリック教の方々が仏教を学んで
ものすごく納得いくんですね
納得いくんだけど 仕方がないね
うちはカトリック教だから
で また教会の言い方に戻っちゃう
その場合は まあうちは家はもうそうだから
そこでしがみつく 何でも捨てる
捨てて真理に行くという勇気が大事な立派な人間の性格なんです
だから恐れなく間違ったものを捨てて
正しいと思うものに行く
そちらはあまりよくないと分かったらさらに上に行く
それもよくないわだったらさらに上に行くというね
階段上りのやり方ね 階段上る時は手すりをつかまりますよ
でも離してほしいね 捕まったまんまでいると
その一歩しか登れませんね
ありがたく手すりのおかげで登ったんですね
次離してほしい 離して上のところ捕まってほしい
頂上に乗ったら手すりはないんですね
だから取って離す 見解は取って離す
取って離すやり方で人は進まなくちゃいけない
このバラモンはもう資格あるんですね
あったんですね 捨てたんだから
はい 次 もうバラモンは変わったんですね
変わったら ボンナー長老に責任が入っているんです
これからちゃんと生き方を教えなくちゃいけない
この人は食欲をやめただけなんですね
そこで順番で教えていくんです
うん ［外国語］お腹出しますけど
ボンナーにが曰く 食欲のためのこの衣はあなたのものにしておいてください
私は衣が欲しくありません
もしもあなたが苦しみを恐れ
苦しみを厭うならば また続きますね
まあもっと優しい いい
これいいです 持ち帰ってくださいと
私には しょうがありませんと
このままね しかし あなたは苦しみが恐れているでしょう
また 苦しみが嫌でしょう
だったら
マーカーシパーパカンカンマンアーリーワヤギワラウサチーチャパーパカンカンマンカリッサシカロシワあらわにもあるいは秘密にでも悪い行いをなさいますな
そもそもあなたがいつか悪い行いをしようとするならば
あるいは現にするならば
ようわからないね そんな難しくないんです
意味は あらわにも内緒でも秘密でも悪いことをしないでください
そこで今あなたやってる現在やっている悪いことをやめてください
これからも同じやり方でやめてください
いわゆるこの人の生活のな
生活の中で悪いことをやってやらなくちゃあかんことあったでしょうにね
やめてください 今日だけじゃなくて
これからも悪をやらないということをやってくださいと
次は
言うんですね ナテードッカーパムーパパムッキャッティウペーチャーピパラヤトサチェーバハヤテドッカッササチェーテドッカマッピアあなたは空中に飛び上がって逃げて
も
苦しみから離脱することはできません
もしもあなたが苦しみを恐れ
もしもあなたが苦しみを厭としても
で これ注あります えーと
あなたは苦しみは嫌ですね
ですから この悪をしないことにしてくださいと
いくらなんでも悪をしちゃうと逃げ場がないんだよと
悪をしたら 水に入ったからといって苦しみから逃げませんと
こちらの空中に飛び上がってっていうことは
このウペッチャーピパラヤトウペッチャーっていうのは別に空中に飛ぶって意味がないんですね
逃げて逃げる 飛び出 飛び上がって逃げる
ウサギさんみたいにね
ちょっと怖くなったらパンパンって飛んで逃げちゃうでしょ
こうやって悪の結果が出てくる苦しみから逃げちゃえばいいんですよ
それは逃げられませんよ
それ悪だけじゃないんですよ
善 苦 業で だから持する業
これは持して自分で持っているんですね
どこにでも 持する 創設する業
で これは注ですから 私の言葉なんですね
業は自分の影が自分から離れないように
業はその行為をした生命から離れません
上の業はいらないね 自分の影が自分から離れないようにね
影から逃げられませんね
どこ行ってもついてくる
これはダンマパダのあれでね
業っていうのは その行為をした生命から離れません
仏教の場合は悪だけじゃないんです
善悪両方両方ですね 行為の結果
いつでも自分で持っているんです
自分から離すことはできないんです
理由があります 生命 生き物とは心の機能があるという意味ですね
生命の定義なんですかね
心が認識しているんですね
いわゆる認識機能があるんで
心がという主語は言えません
認識機能があるんですね
だから生き物ですね だけど
行為をするたびに心にインパクトが入ります
ですから 一つ認識して行為をする
その時の認識が生まれる
その認識にその経験がもう入っているんですね
瞬間瞬間心が消滅して流れる時
滅する心の情報を新たに生まれる生じる心がコピーします
だからいつでも認識する心が必要ですね
心が瞬間消滅します 消滅するんだけど
滅する心 生じる心が滅する
滅す 滅するになる心をコピーするんです
だからどうしようもないんです
それは心の法則です だから心を変容するために時間がかかるのはそういうわけ
例えば  1 年間恨みで悩んでた人に 30 秒で 1 分で心明るい人間にすることはできません
だから喋って喋って いろんなことをやらせて
環境を変えて 結構苦労しなくちゃいけない
だって前の心は今の心をコピーするんだから
あれは完璧にコピーじゃないね
それは新たな心 新たな心
しかし ある程度コピーはします
遺伝子の働きは物質的ですけど
遺伝子だけ変ですよ 物質はコピーする必要はないんですね
物質はコピーしてもらうならありがたいんですよね
1  2万円ぐらいどこかに置いておけば
それをコピーして 1ヶ月経ったら
ああ あら  8万円になると
[笑い] で それはないんですね
物質はコピーしないです
なのに遺伝子はコピーするんですよ
遺伝子はなんか変です
遺伝子って物質でしょう
でコピーする場合はぴったしのコピーじゃないんですね
どこか似ていて どこか似てないって
だから私が生まれた時の遺伝子はもうとっくにないんです
コピーするたびに違うんだけど
メインプログラムはメインプログラムで
よく見ると自分が自分の両親のいろいろ癖やらね
いろいろ持ってるんですね
私の声でもね 私の家の声なんです
声が  2  3回自分の声にびっくりしたことがある
はい お兄ちゃん [笑い] お兄ちゃんでは自分
あれ え？姉ちゃんなの？って自分の声似ているんですよ
似てる てるんだけど 私の方が私の声で姉ちゃんの声
姉ちゃんの声なんで もうもう別に女性ですからね
時々そんだけ親戚で兄弟相手と喋ってたらちょっと気持ち悪くなる時もあります
あんまりともこういうとこ
そういうところ似ていてね
だからだからと言ってまるっきりコピーじゃないんですね
コロンじゃないんですね
だから心もそう だから心はそういう法則だから
遺伝子はそういう法則になっているんです
心は道具使ってますから
認知するために 心の道具が遺伝子なんですね
だから心が遺伝子をコピーさせていくんですね
だから遺伝子読み取ったら将来がんになりましょうと言われても
心でがん発生しないようにすることはできます
コピーする場合はそれではなくて別なもの
あるいはデータとして置いておいて
発生はしません だから遺伝子
がんになった細胞の遺伝子は違うでしょ
だからそこはまあ遺伝子読み取ってみてね
あなた何の病気もなく健康で長生きしますよと言ったっても
心の働き方によって病気になって廃人にする可能性はあります
私も遺伝子私は読んでもらいましたけど
だったら遺伝子のプログラムが正しいければ
もうとっくに死んでるはずなんです
いいポイントは一つもなかったんで
いろんなプログラム読んでみたら
これでダメでこれでなるほど
もう死んでるんですねとかね
でもね それまるっきり違いますね
あの分厚い本で全部来たんだけどね
で 見て なるほど 私は死んでる
はいはいはいはい 残念だと
だからこの 心の持ち方によって遺伝子のコピー説も変えることができます
それで業から離れないのは
我々にとっては心から離れられないんですね
だって命とは心ですからね
だから我々はすごい気をつけなくちゃいけない
行為するときは行為して騙すことはできないし
隠すことはできない 心がやったんだからね
心にそのインパクトが入るんです
はい これであの人にまず一般的な生き方を教えたんですね
隠れてでも公ででも悪いことをしないでください
なぜならば あなたはすごく苦しみを恐れている
だから バラモン人にその性格がなければ
この話はもう 聞き逃しちゃうんです
このバラモン人がえらいもうすごい神経質でああだけはやりたくない
苦しみ嫌なんです だからもうやめなさいと
やめないまでも この人の社会環境でやったことでしょうね
おそらく だからもうちょっといい方法を教えるんです
ウペイヒサラナンブッダン
ブッダに帰依してください
ダンマンサンガンチャターディナン
あのターディっていうのはこの
揺らぎない安穏に達している
これは見事なブッダで何が見事ですかね
これはよくわからない
なんで見事そのように見事なブッダとって書いてますかね
ウペイヒサラナンブッダン
ブッダに帰依しなさい
ダンマンサンガン ダンマとサンガね
仏法僧に帰依しなさい
ターディナン ターディっていうのは
こんな曖昧中途半端揺らぎのない安穏に達しているということです
サマーディヤーヒシーラーニ
戒律を受けてください
私はこのこの戒を守りますと言葉で言って受け取ってほしい
これ自分との約束 神との約束じゃない
仏法僧との約束ではないんです
戒律の場合は 私は今日からこういうこういう戒律を守りますと自分で約束する
そうすると守れる 正直な人は守りますよ
そうすればあなたのためになるでしょう
これであなたはこれで凄く幸せになりますよ
はい バラモン人には言うので
ウピーミサラナム ブッダダンマンサーンガニターティナンサマーディヨシーランタンメアッタヤヒーヒーヒティ
バラモンよく 私はそのような見事なブッダと真理の教えと修行者の集いとに帰依します
もろもろの戒めを保ちます
そうすれば私のためになるでしょう
このバラモン このバラモンは後出家するんですね
これは入ってないんです
この偈の中に 真面目な人だからね
だから罪を犯してこないんです
だから 在家では 自分の在家ではね
どんな仕事をしてたか何だか分からないんだからね
罪を犯す羽目になっちゃうんだから
まあいいや もう出家をしますと
家丸ごと捨てますと 出家したんですね
えらい真剣 出家したら当然真剣
真面目に修行します 善も悪も乗り越える境地に達するんです
ブッダ長老のこの歌 長老の歌なのに
長老の解脱に達したエピソードも省略できます
本当は長老の歌の場合は
私はこのように修行して
このように煩悩をなくして阿羅漢果に達しました
三明を得たとかで終了しなくちゃいけないんです
このフォーマットがないんです
だから長老の歌として一部欠けているんです
だから私は丁寧に省略しているんだと
本当は欠けてますけど
で このところを注釈書で補っていますね
注釈書も長いんです これは
何ページあるんですかね
ちっちゃな文字で見させたら七ページです
解脱に達する ブラッマバンドゥプーレーアーシンアッジャッミサッチャブラァマノー
テーヴィッジョーヴェーダサンパンノーすっぴよちゃんみなあてこう
以前には私は梵天の親族であったが
今では私は真のバラモンである
なんかよくブラッマバンドゥっていうのはバラモンって意味なんですね
文字では梵天の親族 だから言葉二つあるんです
あなたはバラモン人 あんたは梵天の親族
どちらでも同じ意味なんです
単語違うだけで だから私は昔はバラモンでしたけど
今はバラモンですと意味なんです
昔も今もバラモンではなくて
昔はバラモンでしたけど
バラモンカーストの 今は本物ですと
本物のバラモン サッチャブラフマン
真理のバラモン いわゆる聖者ですね
テーヴィッジョヴェーダサンパーナ
そこで昔はヴェーダ 三つあるんです
リグヴェーダ ヤジュルヴェーダ
サーマヴェーダという
ヴェーダは四つですけど
あまりバラモン 伝統的なバラモン人は三ヴェーダというんです
四番目のヴェーダはバラモンカースト以外
インドの土着的な信仰をまとめていろいろまとめて作ったテキストなんですね
呪文はそちらにあるんです
えーと それで昔はただのくだらないヴェーダ
聖典のね 知識人でいたけど
今は本当に三明を持ってますよと
いわゆる悟りは三明というんですね
私は三つの名誉を備え
真の黙許者である 学識豊かな神のヴェーダ学者であるとかね
なんか意味がごちゃごちゃになってますよ
これは文 文化的に意味しなくちゃいけない
ブラッマバンドゥプレアーシン
梵天の親戚でありましたということは
昔はバラモン人であった
ただ いえ アッジャミサッチャブラフマン
今は本物のバラモン いわゆる解脱にサティ
達しているんです 本物の聖者
テーヴィッジョヴェーダサンパーナ
昔もヴェーダを知っていた
三つの 今本物を知っている
いわゆる三明 過去を見る力と
業を発見する力と 煩悩を亡くなったという知恵
三つですね 相当瞑想したんでしょう
このバラモン ソッティヨ
ソッティっていうのはこの
いろいろ修行するっていう
黙欲するっていうね 昔は密に入って黙欲してたんだけど
今本物の黙欲してるんで
いわゆる心綺麗になっているんだと
だからインチキ黙欲から本物の黙欲になっちゃいます
立ちました インチキヴェーダ聖典から本物の知恵に達しました
インチキバラモンから本物のバラモンになりましたと
ということで 自分が解脱に達したと表現しているんですね
結構派手に 終わったんですね
はい これで なんで私はバラモン人を褒め称えるとわかる？ポイント
結局はバラモン人が解脱に達したことで
この歌が完結しているんです
プンナーアマさんがどこかに隠れているんです
プンナーハラカンニが
私がこれこれで悟りましたという自慢のフレーズがないんです
だからプンナーアマさんのね
長老尼の歌といっても
結局はこの偉大なるバラモンの方のことを歌っているんですね
はい それで話が終わります
はい まあ時間が早く終わると思ったって結構じゃあ取ってしまいました
何かご感想等おっしゃいますか
はい  パンニカさんとバラモンが使う言葉なんですけれども
なんで階層で使う単語とかが
使う単語とか言葉が違うのか
違いが出てきちゃうのか
どこら辺？ 最初の方ですね
最初の方の話で パンニカさんとバラモンの使う言葉がちょっと違うという話があったと思うんですけれども
ちょっと意味がこない
バラモンとプンナーさんの使う言葉が違うっていうことがどういうことなのかわからない
え？言ってるんですけど
カースト制度の  え？ カースト制度の言葉の差を言ってらっしゃるんですか？最初に
最初 最初先生がこの詩はパンニカさんが作った詩じゃないんじゃないかっていう
ああ それはパーリ語自体がすごい人格のある
すごい超エリートでなければ使えない言語なんですね
プンナっていうのはもともと召使なんですね
奴隷と同じレベルなんですね
だから一切教育はないんです
先生 でもパーリ語って日常語だったんじゃないですか
日常でもこれは一般人すごい言語違うんです
でもインドの場合はそれ普通なの
例えばシンハラ語で我々説法するとき
使うシンハラ語は一般人には喋れないんです
だから何て言いますか
この会話言語というね
言語があるんです 日常会話
言語 それは地方によっていろいろ発音が変わったり
いろいろあるんです だからプンナさんも言語を喋ってるんだから
この会話言語は喋りますけど
このアカデミックランゲージは使いません
これ 英語でもありますよ
普通のそれほど学問ない英語を喋る人々の英語と
しっかりと立派な大学出ている人々が喋る英語は違うわけですね
そういう意味でこのパニカさんでは作れないという感じ
そういうふうにね  でもこう
なんかあのプンナさんですよ
名前は プンニカーとかこの中村先生訳してますけど
プンナさんですね  本人は書いてないかもしれないけれども
時代を超えてこの話を伝えなきゃいけないから
シンプルな言葉では時代を超えられないって
誰か思ってこういう詞にしたんじゃないかなと
まあまあ 経典ね 作っている時代で
このこんな長老とこのバラモン人のエピソードがすごい典型的で大変大事なエピソードなんですね
そのメッセージがすごく大事なんですよ
このしきたり 習慣にこだわるなよと
私は今日も言いたかったんだけど
この回向宗というね 宗教やる人々は何かしきたり
何か習慣 何か儀式に引っかかっているんです
どんな宗教も儀式ばっかしなんですね
仏教を見たらどうですかね
儀式 儀式 儀式 儀式 それじゃないんだよと
お寺に行ったことあるでしょうね
いろいろ 儀式ばっかしでもうすごい真剣にやってますよ
出がせ出だせながら 仏教はそう
ブッダの教えはそういう儀式は一切ないんです
だからこちらでこの儀式のバカバカしさを歌っているんですね
だからプンナ大阿羅漢に自分で詩を作れなかったかもしれませんだけど
どなたかの他も阿羅漢
阿羅漢が作った歌だと分かりますよ
なんで私が言ったいろいろ人をけなすとかね
ないないんだから 本当は
すごい丁寧な すごい優しい言葉で言ってますから
もともと心の煩悩がない方々が作った詩だと思います
だからプンナテーリがこう言ったというのは構いません
プンナテーリも阿羅漢でしょうし
裸になったら女性男性って何もないんだからね
これは私個人の考えですよ
こんなこれはテーラワーダのお坊さんに言っちゃうと殺されるかもしれませんだけど
あのミャンマーなんて言ったら言わないでください
[笑い]大阿羅漢が言ったことやというふうに言わないと
全部はそうなんですけど
私はやっぱりどう考えても無理がない
これは大乗で こんな長老の歌を通してね
聞いたとは思います はい
はい その このバラモンは
その悪をするのを悪を非常に恐れていた
ですよね その恐れていた悪っていうのは一体何なんですか
それはまあ その人の世界で何か考えたでしょうね
だからいろんな世界ではね
いろんな悪を考えているんですよ
でも基本その いろんな悪がありますよね
いや 仏教でいう悪と そのバラモンでいうところの悪っていうのは違うんじゃないですか
違うでしょうと思います
私も 今思い出したのは
あの神様のために生贄をするという習慣があるでしょ
あります  今もやってますよ
鶏やらいろいろ首を切って
イスラム教必ず一年二
三回やってますからね
ユダヤ人も一年一回か二回か
もう鶏を首を切って神様に差し上げると
生贄やってますよ これ
でもその方々にとっては殺生が善行為なんですね
やらなくてはいけない
あの YOUTUBEである動画見たんだけど
このある あのトルコかどこかのちょっとヨーロッパに近いイスラムの家ですけど
あのイスラム教のその日でこの儀式をやるために
お父さんが鶏を買ってきたんですね
鶏を買ってきて 鶏が遊んでるんです
それ娘 ちっちゃな女の子がいて
女の子が鶏と仲良くなっちゃって
もう可愛くてたまらないんですね
ちょうどこの儀式の日で
お父さんが包丁を持って首を切ろうとね
やっても娘が飛んできて鶏を守ってあげる
殺さないよとかね できなくなっちゃう
何回やったっても ちっちゃな女の子はこれをやらせないんですね
それで彼が言うんですね
あの 鶏を殺して殺してサクリファイスすることは正しいこと It
is allowedと彼が言うんですね Allowed
なんですけど この娘さんがやらせてくれないんだと
だからその人にとっては娘さんが悪行をやっているんですね
コーランで決めている善行為をやらせてくれないんですね
そこでポイントは そうやって人間勝手に善悪を決めている
はい それでもそれ破っちゃうとやっぱり痛いんですよ
心が 悪いことしちゃったとかね
例えば日本の神道の場所いろいろありますね
そちらにこれ以上入るなよというところあるんですね
厳しい神様のところは
あの そういう神の仕事をする人々しか入らない
ちょっとなんとか隠れてすっと入ったとしましょう
何のこともないんだけど
でもやっぱり日本文化の人だったらこんなことやっていいんでしょうかねとかね
ちょっとまずいんじゃない？とか思ったりする
そういうわけで この人間が勝手に善悪を決めてるんだけど
それは仏教的に善ではない
悪ではないかもしれませんだけど
個人を悩みさせることは大いにあるんですね
ジャイナ教ではジャイナ
在家ではなく出家が水を使ってはいけないんです
なぜならば水にも魂がある
だから普通の水を使ったりすると殺生したことになる
今あんまり厳しく守ってないんだけど
だからジャイナの修行者が托鉢に出たら
お湯を在家の人々はお湯をあげるんですね
お湯はもう大丈夫です
飲んでも水飲まなきゃもう大変苦しいんだけど
苦行が修行だからそれは構いませんし
時々ジャイナ教は旅に出る時は時々川を渡らなくちゃいけない
向こうに行く場合は川を渡るんですよ
ものすごいあの方々 心痛むみたいに殺生しちゃってどうしようもないと
それで川を渡った途端
あの罰としてあの砂を運んで砂の山をして懺悔する
メスを歩いたんだからどうったことないでしょ
でもあの方々は変なメスに魂があるという迷信で罪を犯しているとな
心は悩みますよ 問題はそこなんです
罪を犯して罪を犯したと落ち込むんですよ
だからそれが悪行になっちゃうんです
心が落ち込んだこと そこで死んじゃったら悩みながら死ぬんだから
こんな罪を犯したままで死んじゃったら
ろくなところに生まれ変われません
ろくなところに生まれ変われなくなっちゃう
そこでこのおっしゃったポイントは大事なポイントですよ
だからバラモン人にまず表にでも内緒でも罪を犯すなよと言った
それはバラモン人が考える罪の世界なんですね
善悪の世界なんですね
次に やっぱり仏法に帰依して戒律を守ってくださいと仏教が推薦する善悪世界を紹介するんです
その人はあれを捨ててこちらに入るんですね
例えば殺生するなよという殺生することは罪であると言ってますけど
イスラム教 キリスト教の場合は人を殺すことだけ悪いんですね
動物を殺すのは構いません
なぜ魂がないんだと というようなんです
殺生ならもう命生き物を殺すことは殺生になるんだけどね
それはまあイスラム教とかそういういくつかの宗教以外は普通にそう思ってるんですね
だから人間の善悪の考えはそれぞれバラバラ
バラバラだからといっても悩むことには同じなんですよ
で そのこのバラモンはすごく真面目な人だったから
真面目に悩んでたんですね
プンナさんの言葉を聞いて
で 自分のやっていることでは苦しみはなくならないと
そのバラモンこのバラモンが感じている苦しみっていうのは苦しみなんですか？ それは普通の苦しみなんて
それもまあまあ普通に生きることは苦しみだから
いろいろ大変でしょうね
悩んでたでしょうね まあ苦しみ自体は誰にだって同じように感じちゃいますからね
例えば せっかく生まれてきた子供が死んじゃったらね
何人とか関係ないでしょ
悲しいでしょうに お腹が空いているんだけど
食べるものを買うお金がないと
それ苦しいでしょ これには何人っていうことはないでしょう
だから苦しみについて
別に宗教の文化の差がないんですね
善悪は何なのかと言っちゃうと
もう文化の差が 民族の差
宗教の差が出てくるんです
苦しみは人類誰だって人類誰だってじゃなくて
動物も同じなんですね
でもこのバラモンは その苦しみをその水浴び
冷たい水をかぶることによって少し軽くなるように感じてたんですよね
信じていたんですね  信じていたんですよね
その水浴びをその手放した時
彼は心細くなかったのかしら
うーん だから だからそこ
突っ込んだところそこなんですね
だからあなたやってることは結局は悪行為だよと言われちゃったんだからね
だってあなた 善も悪も全て流しちゃってね
とんでもないものになっちゃうんだよ
だからそれが一番恐れるんですよ
立派な人格者になりたかったんだから
だからものすごくびっくりして怖くなっちゃって
直ちに全て捨てちゃったんです
言葉を換えると 善を行って悪を痛めるといった思ってやったことは悪行為であったと
結局は自分が悪行為ばっかりやっていたんだと
家でも悪行為して沐浴すると
とんでもない また悪行為やっちゃって
こんな危険なことやめたとということになったんですね
それからお釈迦様の教えを聞いたんですよね
出家してからね 出家した場合でも
こんな尼さんに出家できないでしょ
男性だから それから他のブッダの仏別のところで出家して,もう真面目に修行して
阿羅漢になるんです きっかけを作ったのはプンナという長老になんですね
この人に道を見せたのはね
道に入れてあげたのはプンナという長老なんだ
でもプンナという長老は
そのお前のやってることは悪行為だよって教えはしたけども
道は教えてないんじゃないですか
教えていますよ 三宝に帰依することをここからね
だから自分にはとってはそれまでできないしかできないんですね
ですから 私にできることをやりました
という意味なんですね
だから あなたもっと優れた罪のない悪のない人間になりたければ
仏法僧に帰依して そちらはもう戒律を守って頑張ってみてと
もう任せちゃう サンガに任せちゃったんですね
お母さんが自分の子供を頑張って学校に入れてあげる
それから学校で教えてあげるでしょうね
そういう感じで こんな長老尼が自分にできることはやってあげた
仏道に入ってくださいと言ったんですね
それから本人が行って仏道に入る
私はこの言う通りに素直にやるっていうことは面白くてね
珍しくて だからこの長老尼の歌なのに
結局はこの素晴らしいキャラのバラモン人のことを歌われているんですね
それから はい わかりました
ありがとうございます
ではどうします？何か
ちょっと同じポイントをしてしまうような気がしますけど
バラモン人の方がですね
追憶ですか これをあなたに差し上げますと言った時に
そこでなんか落ち着いてしまったような感じがしたんですけど
本当はもたついてるかもしれませんけど
その時にですね まだ動揺してるはずだと思った
なので私はどうしたらいいんですかっていうセリフのほうが先に出てこないとおかしいんじゃないかなという気はしたんですけど
どうですか  あったかもね
そこはまあ この歌の場合はもういろいろリミットがありますから
この十六声ですから あの芸の数も決まってるしね
いろいろあるんで そこはなんとなく我々に補うことはできるんだからね
で どうすればいいか これからって困ったところで
悪を犯すなよと そんなこと言われたって困りますと言ったでしょうね
私はこういう仕事だからとか
だったら仏法僧聞きしなさい
戒律守ってくださいと言ったでしょうね
そういうふうに会話が長く行ったと思いますよ
そこでハイライトポイントだけ歌にしているんです
うん はい まあ時間的にはまあね
どうもありがとうございます
出版記念書に先生にサインをいただきたいという方が 2
枚 こちらにサインを お願いします
カバンでも  こんなに  大丈夫ですか？